Congress faces some crucial deadlines
federal courts will run out of money in
three days and some 800,000 federal
employees will miss their second
paycheck in nine days more federal
housing assistant contracts will start
to expire in February NASA's Jet
Propulsion lab may need to cut staff and
the Census Bureau's budget could run dry
ahead of the 2020 sentence in 10 days
rent subsidies will run out for nearly
270,000 low-income rural families two
days after that the State Department
will need more money to meet its payroll
and in 17 days federal employees will
miss their third paycheck Susan page is
Washington bureau chief for USA Today
Susan good morning good morning
it is long past due for a legislative
and executive remedy to this what is
Congress going to do this week and will
it work well I don't think it's gonna
work Congress is going to take steps
this week to show each side that they're
making some efforts but they're not
talking to each other they're just
talking at each other and both sides of
it rejected the other side's proposals
as complete non starters this political
pressure normally work and these kind of
things both sides have drilled down so
heavily you know traditionally political
pressure would have worked we know that
President Trump is taking the brunt of
the blame from a series of polls
traditionally that would have pushed the
White House to make some kind of deal
political pressure isn't working this
time I think reality might work look at
the things that Nora just talked about
the real impact on Americans both the
federal workers and everybody else and
if there's a time when people cannot fly
commercially because there just aren't
enough TSA agents to do the security
that's what might finally push it if the
TSA really took action and it they could
totally shut down the city because more
powerful than economy rather I guess we
keep hearing about the president being
so close to a deal and then being
beholden to people like Ann Coulter and
even Fox News how factual is that how
much does he rely on their voice you
know we had a deal the guard the country
had a deal last month to keep funding
the government and the president
initially agreed to it and then walked
away from it because he was criticized
by Ann Coulter and Rush Limbaugh and
that's one reason Democrats are very
nervous about making another deal with
him will he follow through with it
that's one of the things that makes it
hard to see your way out of this impasse
tonight except we see and with a new
poll out this morning
that Republicans increasingly blame the
president for the shutdown to Gales
point the political pressure will we see
Republicans in Congress start to cleave
from the president's well one of the
mysteries of the past two years with
President Trump is that Republicans have
not done that Paul Ryan didn't do that
Mitch McConnell has not done that but
you know there is Donald Rumsfeld used
to have us saying that if you can't
solve a problem make it bigger and it
seems to me that that is one way out of
this if you've had a big deal a deal
that gave permit of production to the
dreamers in exchange for giving
President Trump some money he could say
was for as well that might be a path a
so who could be the knight in shining
armor here or knights in shining armor
well you know Senate Republican Senate
Republicans are in a position to really
push the White House that's one
possibility
TSA agents are we looking to them
Democrats have really dug in their heels
said no to his most recent proposal one
of the reasons being that his daca deal
does not offer a pathway to citizenship
one of the reasons I've heard is that
the Nancy Pelosi and others do not want
to reward what they view as bad behavior
from the president if he thinks that he
can get away with this that he can do it
again in the future is that true yes I
think it's true that they're worried
about setting a precedent that you just
shut down the government and then you
get something that you would otherwise
not be able to get so I do think that is
that is part of it but Democrats also
are anxious this week to show that they
number one are willing to go some
distance
number two willing to give a little more
money for border security and that
doesn't actually I think get you closer
to a deal but it does indicate that
there is some nervousness about standing
at this stand we just saw senator Kamala
Harris threw her hat into the ring a
number of women certainly on the
Democratic side a record number running
for president Peggy Noonan's got a piece
in The Wall Street Journal today which
she writes about it's harder to be a
public woman in America than a public
man and harder to be a female candidate
will that change in 2020 it's it may not
change but it is changing yeah you know
we've had women run for president even
before Hillary Clinton they were not
taken seriously as potential nominees
all for the women that we think are
running this time are taken seriously as
potential nominees and that is a sea
change Susan we got to go but can we
just say congratulations on your new
book deal writing about Nancy Pelosi
people
the most powerful woman in the country
yes and first your book on Barbara Bush
well so women from both political
parties very exciting thanks Susan
you're very busy
appreciate you taking the time they come
here